The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
OLIVIER DE WECK: So
let's get to work.
The V-Model, well,
believe it or not,
but we've arrived today
at the bottom of it,
the pointy part of the V. We're
arriving at the bottom of it,
and the bottom of
it is basically you
driving down the design in all
its glory and all its details.
And we call this
design definition,
and then I want to talk about
multidisciplinary optimization,
including what happens at
the CDR, the critical design
review.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: All right, I
do have a quick question
about A4 based to this.
Do you want a CAD drawing
or a hand drawing?
OLIVIER DE WECK: I'm fine with
a nice dimension hand drawing,
but we're gonna talk
about CAD next week.
So I do think it would be
good to have a CAD drawing,
but you know CAD drawings can
come in very different levels
of detail, right?
So I think it would be
good to have an idea,
if the PDR package--
most of the PDR
packages that you
see that have been submitted
in prior years at CanSat,
they do have a CAD
drawing in there
for their sort of
suggested configuration.
And you know, it is
useful because you
get to see whether the
packaging concept really works.
You know, the sketching,
you can get away
with a lot just sketching.
So my answer would
tend to be yes,
but if absolutely,
you don't feel
like you need it or you
don't want to do it,
then a nice hand drawing with
dimensions will do as well.
OK, so let's talk about
the bottom of the V.
The other thing I'm
gonna cover today
is this idea of
multidisciplinary design
optimization, and so
where does that fit in?
So you remember we talked about
concept synthesis, concept
generation, screening,
and selection,
and then at the PDR
stage, you know,
we picked one architecture.
So today's topic
is really how do
you get this architecture,
which is shown as this square
here to an optimal?
And I put optimal in
quotes here because we're
gonna argue what that means, but
you've refined the design, such
that you can go
present it at the CDR.
So you take this box here,
which is your concept,
and you open the box--
you can see this on the right--
and you really dive
into the details
of the various
subsystems and components
and how they're connected.
And what you're trying to
do is fine tune your design.
So this is shown
here schematically.
Let's say there's a
design variable X1
and you want to find where
is the optimal point?
This point here seems to
be optimal to minimize
metric three and
that's the design
that you're gonna propose.
So today's topic really is
about fine tuning the design
and coming up with a
CDR level design, that's
what we want to talk about.
And so what I'll cover
is different topics.
So first of all, the
NASA view of this.
It's called the design
definition process.
Then I'll talk about MDO,
multidisciplinary design
optimization, the use
of so-called CDFs,
concurrent design
facilities, and then
finally, what happens at CDR.
So the general idea of the
design solution definition
process is that you
start with something
like this on the left.
This is a product breakdown
structure, essentially
your system architecture,
your system decomposition.
And on the right side,
you then translate this
to a detailed design, OK?
So for a launch
vehicle, we have,
you know, the flight segment,
this is what-- actually it's
gonna fly and it has a payload
element, the spacecraft
bus, and then the launch and
the launch accommodation.
So that's the general idea is
you have high-level breakdown,
but then you need to
design every piece.
You need to have
chosen your materials.
chosen the dimensions.
You need to understand
the interfaces.
And for every part, you
also need to decide what?
What's a big decision
that you need
to make when you go to
the detailed design,
beside, you know, material,
dimensions, software?
What is always a
big decision to make
when you do a detailed design?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Maybe the
interfaces between the two.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yep,
interfaces, all that.
What I'm trying
to get at is COTS.
Who knows this acronym, COTS?
Let's see if the, EPFL,
anybody know COTS?
What does it mean?
I think we can't
hear you right now.
AUDIENCE: Commercial
off the shelf.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Commercial off the shelf.
So you have to decide
in the detailed design
are you going to pick
components from a catalog,
or are you going to custom
design these components, right?
And so one of the
things at the CDR, that
I always ask the question--
so you present your CDR design.
What percentage, what fraction
of your parts at the lowest
level are COTS and what
fraction did you custom design?
Mike, you've done a lot of
these unmanned aerial vehicles
and so forth.
Can you talk a
little bit about, you
know, what's the typical
fraction of COTS,
and how do you make that
decision when you design,
you know, a flying thing?
AUDIENCE: It really depends
on the scale and how robust.
The problem with COTS
in the unmanned world
is that you can easily
go to hobby grade parts.
And so if you want to get into
more of the commercial, kind
of more robust, almost
more like defense
kind of, like,
robustness and you know,
durability, you
really have to start
going to custom designed parts.
Because you know, if you
can do a whole design
space of, you know, all the
COTS parts, but you know,
they're always just
kind of, you now,
Chinese-made electric motors
and batteries, and none of them
that will perform to,
like, commercial spec,
but it just depends, really,
what you need for the vehicle.
OLIVIER DE WECK: I see.
So what you're saying
is there's a gap.
You can get a lot of COTS stuff
at the hobby shop level, right?
So they're pretty affordable
but low reliability.
Or you have really high end,
very expensive, you know,
low production--
AUDIENCE: Like traditional
aerospace grade, yeah.
OLIVIER DE WECK: But there's
not much in the middle.
Is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, good.
So you know, that's the
reality of detailed design
that you're gonna face.
And surprisingly, in kind of
the formal system engineering
methodology, there's not
a lot of guidance on this.
There's not a lot of,
you know, guidance
to say what's the
optimal fraction
of commercial off
the shelf parts?
This is really something you
have to work out yourself,
and depending on, you know,
whether you're in aerospace
or medical devices or automotive
or making toothpaste, there's--
actually, yesterday
there was also
a big case study on diapers.
Diapers is a $3 billion
business, believe it or not.
And they were going
for-- their solution
A was to go for a COTS solution,
you know, a lot of vendors.
And then they said, no.
It's just gonna give
us, sort of, average,
mediocre performance.
We want something much better.
So they went for a much
higher custom design solution.
Took them took them
a while to do it,
but it was worth it in the end.
So this is a big decision
you have to make.
So the point here
being, at the end,
you have a very detailed design.
You have blueprints.
You have something you
can actually build.
So you know, this is a list of
all the things you need to do.
You define the solution space,
develop your alternatives.
All the things
we've already talked
about at the conceptual level,
but you do this at every-- you
do it at the subsystem
level, and even
at the component level.
What are the alternate designs?
Cost performance and schedule.
Select your design
solution, drive it down
to the lowest level of
detail, and then identify
the enabling products, which
would be like support equipment
and things like this.
So the best illustration
I can give you
why this matters is these two
pictures I'm gonna show you.
The top picture
that you see here,
this is a picture that was drawn
in the '70s to sell the space
shuttle program to US Congress.
This was the vision, right?
This is the orbiter,
and you can see
it's sitting there in this
pristine hangar, right, very
clean, shiny floors,
maybe four or five people.
The payload bay is open.
There's, like, one or two carts
of ground support equipment.
You just load up your new
satellite, close the doors,
and off you go for
your next mission.
That's a reusable vehicle.
That's what we wanted, and then
what we actually got is this.
You can't even see
the orbiter, right?
But I promise you,
it's in there.
It's hidden in that scaffolding.
So this was the--
it's retired now,
but this was the orbiter
processing facility at the NASA
Kennedy Space Center.
And the reality was
that to turn around
an orbiter between flights
was almost like rebuilding it.
And the two subsystems that
required the most person hours
of work were the main engine--
the main engine basically had
to be disassembled and inspected
and so forth--
and what was the other system?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Heat shield.
OLIVIER DE WECK: The
heat shield, the TPS,
thermal protection system--
if you've ever seen--
who's seen the shuttle close up?
OK, about half, half here.
At EPFL, who's had a
chance to see the space
shuttle, the orbiter, close up?
Anybody?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: One or two.
OLIVIER DE WECK: One or two.
So those of you
that have seen it,
what did you notice
about the heat shield?
Did you notice anything
about the protection,
the thermal protection system?
Who's seen it?
AUDIENCE: We do not
hear very well here.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
You can't hear me?
So the point I want
to make here is
that the thermal protection
system, every tile
is different.
Every tile has a different
shape, a different curvature,
and there were good
thermodynamic reasons,
aerothermodynamic
reasons for that,
but in terms of actually
designing, manufacturing,
and turning around the vehicle,
it was a nightmare, right?
So that it turned out to be
not a very reusable vehicle
in the end, and why?
Because a lot of
the detailed design
decisions ended
up being critical,
in terms of not really
giving us what we wanted,
in terms of macro level
properties of the vehicle.
So detailed design
really matters.
Did you get that point, at EPFL?
Is it clear?
AUDIENCE: It is.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, thank you.
So here's some--
I'm not going to go
through this in detail,
but here's some flow diagrams,
process flow diagrams,
from the System
Engineering Handbook
that essentially describe,
you know, how this works.
So your inputs are your baseline
logical decomposition model,
which is essentially your
system architecture, right?
And then your baseline derived,
your detailed technical
requirements.
You go through all
these processes,
through all these
steps, and then you
end up with a whole
bunch of outputs, which
are more detailed requirements.
The specifications,
do you remember,
we teased apart requirements
and specifications?
Requirements are what
the system should do.
Requirement specifications are
how the system's actually been
designed, right, blueprints.
So that's specifications
at the subsystem level.
And then you get other things,
like a verification, validation
plan, and then logistics
and operating procedures.
So very, very detailed work.
The other thing that's
important is all the design
considerations that go
into making detailed design
decisions.
So here's a fairly
long list of them,
and you can group them into
performance, availability.
This is more related
to reliability.
So you could have a system that
has high nominal performance
but is poor reliability,
right, so it's not available
very much.
That's not good.
We want high performance
and high availability.
That gives you your
technical effectiveness.
And then how do you
actually operate the system?
So operations,
maintenance, logistics,
so that's process efficiency.
Together, that gives you
system effectiveness.
And then, of course,
you have the total cost
of operating the system--
lifecycle cost, total ownership
cost.
And then system
effectiveness and cost
together, give you what's called
here affordable operational
effectiveness.
So I would argue, in terms
of the space shuttle program,
it had high system performance.
It had OK system availability.
They had-- definitely there
were some reliability issues,
but it was manageable, but
it had very poor process
efficiency--
operations, maintenance,
logistics very, very difficult.
So system effectiveness wasn't
that high, and as a result,
the lifecycle cost
was also very high.
There's a very
famous paper, where
after the shuttle
program was ended,
a lifecycle cost
analysis was done,
and it turned out that one
launch cost about $1.5 billion.
So during the program,
people would say,
oh, one launch is
maybe $500 million,
you know, the variable cost,
and the rest is fixed cost.
But once the program is done,
it doesn't matter anymore
whether it was fixed
or variable cost.
All you know is what was the
total cost of the program,
how many launches
did we actually do,
and you just take the ratio.
And it was $1.5 billion
per launch of the shuttle.
And so I would say
that's way off from what
the original target was.
Yeah, Veronica?
AUDIENCE: Does that number
account for crew and crew
training?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Good question.
I think so.
I think it basically-- whatever
was appropriated by Congress
for the shuttle
program, and I think
that would include crew
operations, as well, yeah.
So I'm happy to point you
to that paper, actually.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It also accounted
for R&D costs as well, right?
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Yes, that's correct.
It includes everything, all in.
R&D costs-- R&D
took about 10 years
and then operations
was about 30 years.
OK, so you see--
and of course, within
these are budget limits.
So part of the reason
why the shuttle didn't
have that high
process efficiency
was because the R&D budget
was capped pretty tightly.
So rather than
optimizing, you know,
for maintainability
and turnaround,
they said, we need to have
the system performance.
We need to have reasonable
system availability,
and then the rest, basically, is
we're gonna deal with it later.
So what effectively
happened is they capped
R&D cost, and as a result,
the lifecycle cost ballooned.
I would argue if
they had spent, you
know, two or three
more years optimizing,
you know, maintenance
and turn around,
really making it reusable,
the lifecycle costs could
have been much better, but
that's not how it worked.
So you have a lot of these
competing requirements.
And so I want to
just ask you this--
this is the first concept
question today, OK?
So imagine you're-- this
is a very detailed design.
This is just a bracket here, OK?
And this bracket was designed
so it has, like, a tip load.
Think of this as
a cantilever beam.
So it's attached on the
right side or left side here.
You have a load, and then
this is your displacement
under a given load.
And these three brackets
all have the same mass.
They use the same
amount of material, OK?
So you can think of this as you
get from the very simple design
to the more intricate design,
you have more design freedom.
So you get better performance.
You see the
displacement goes down,
but you also have
more complexity.
So it's more
difficult to optimize.
It's more difficult to
manufacture and so forth.
And so we can actually show
these three choices here
on a manufacturing
cost, per unit cost,
versus the displacement,
structural displacement
under load chart.
So our simple design,
our one bar design,
has a displacement of 2.5
millimeters under load,
and it costs about $2 to make.
The two-bar design has
much better performance,
like 0.75 or something like
that, costs about $3 to make.
And then this 17-bar
intricate design
has 0.6 millimeters, so the
best structural performance,
but its cost is
about $8 per piece.
So my question to you is
which of these three designs
would you select and why?
So if you could go to that
link, enter your answer,
and then we'll look
at the distribution.
So we have 39 responses.
That's good.
Ah, interesting.
OK.
So one of you said
you're gonna go
for the super-duper
17-bar design.
Most of you, 74%, said
the two-bar design.
And one of you said one bar.
And then eight of you,
20%, said you're not sure.
I guess you need more
information, right?
So who picked the one-bar
design, the simple design?
OK, so please explain
why you picked that.
AUDIENCE: Well,
for my application.
I'm planning on
mass producing them,
and it's for
something that doesn't
need the degree of displacement
that the other ones are doing,
and so I'm really only seeking
to minimize manufacturing cost,
and the one bar is the
easiest to manufacture
and also gives me
room down the road
to iterate if it's not working.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, so So what
would be an example, industry
or application?
AUDIENCE: Like a
children's toy, perhaps,
where you don't need very strict
requirements on displacement,
something that you're
mass producing.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Something
mass produced, you know,
for sort of lower requirements.
OK, I think that's
a valid answer.
Most of you said
the two-bar design.
So who said two bars?
Let's see at EPFL, who
picked the two-bar design?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
It gives you the biggest
biggest bang for your buck.
For not that much more cost, you
get a much more sturdy design
and that's compared
for the 17-bar one.
Really, it's still
pretty sturdy,
but you're paying much
less, so it seems optimal.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah, so if
you think about this in a Pareto
sense, I mean, they're
all Pareto-optimal,
but this one is at the
knee of the curve, right?
So you're getting, you said
bang for your buck or value.
If you did, like, a displacement
or one over displacement,
I guess, per manufacturing cost,
this one would do pretty well.
So that's also a
very sensible answer.
Who picked the 17-bar design,
the really intricate one?
Who picked that?
Oh, I think I might have picked
that when I tried out the form.
[LAUGHS] I think so.
I can't remember now.
It's been already a while ago.
So if, indeed, I was the one,
so how would I justify this?
OK, so here this
bracket will go--
this will go on the
Mars 2020 Rover.
And the Rover will see a lot
of different thermal gradients.
You know, it has
to be very precise
because it holds
scientific instruments that
need to be, you know,
pointing very accurately.
Even though the mass here
is identical, but I think
we could shrink this.
You know, we get the best
performance structurally
for the mass constraint
that we were allocated.
And cost, you know, this
is all taxpayer dollars,
so this is a government program.
So we can spend the money.
Of course, I don't
mean that really,
but it is a high-performance
application.
Therefore, even though
the benefit is only small,
that small benefit
is worth it when
you look at the whole mission.
So we're we're going
to pay for that,
and we're going to go for
this high-performance design.
Do you see how that works?
So the right answer--
and I think a lot of you said,
you know, you're not sure,
and it's because--
who said you're not sure?
Nathan.
AUDIENCE: I said
not sure because you
don't know all
the specifications
or what the tolerances are
or any other information that
would lead you to
make that decision.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Right,
so you know, what
are the requirements, right?
We don't know the
requirements here.
Are the requirements shall
or should requirements?
If it's a shall
requirement, what it means
is there would be some
hard limit here, right?
The displacement shall be
less than one millimeter.
If that's a hard requirement,
then this solution falls out,
does not satisfy.
And if it's a
should requirement,
then it's a goal that
you're gonna trade off.
The point I want to
make here, this lecture
is about detailed design.
This is detailed design, right?
And you're gonna make hundreds
or thousands of detailed design
decisions just like this
bracket and together,
they're gonna give you, you
know, the performance cost
of your whole system.
And so every detailed
design decision
you make needs to be informed
by the requirements but also
the trade-offs between
these properties.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So and that leads
us-- and so you
want to make sure you
optimize your system.
You want to make sure you get--
and I liked, Katya, the
way you said it-- get
the bang for your buck, right?
You want to make sure you don't
have a lot of inefficiencies
in your design.
So that's what MDO is about.
So let me go to MDO
here, what it is.
So there's a technical committee
in AIAA, the American Institute
for Aeronautics
and Astronautics,
that was founded
about 20 years ago.
So it's defined as an evolving
methodology, a body of methods,
techniques, algorithms,
and related application
practices for the design
of engineering systems,
coupled by physical
phenomena and involving
many interacting
subsystems and parts.
So the main things
you need to do MDO
are a mathematical model of the
system, analysis capability,
and in some cases,
approximation concepts.
So what that means is not--
if you put all this together,
it could be very, very slow
and computationally heavy.
So you might approximate
some of these things,
and I'll explain
a couple examples.
Sensitivity analysis,
optimization processes,
and a human interface-- those
are the main ingredients
of MDO.
Who's seen this chart before?
OK, about three or four of you.
Who's seen this chart before at
EPFL, this particular graphic?
Anybody seen this before?
AUDIENCE: Apparently, no one.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK,
so let me explain.
This is a cartoon, OK, and
I've experienced this myself
working at McDonnell
Douglas in the '90s.
So each of these
airplanes shown here
is what the airplane
would look like
if that particular
discipline or group could
call all the shots, OK?
So let's look at
a couple of these.
So the controls group is
all about controllability.
So you see the flight control
surfaces are very big.
Now, the problem
is the linkages,
you know, these control
linkages are on the outside.
That's really bad
for aerodynamics,
but the controls people say,
I don't care about drag.
I need to make sure my
control surfaces are
deflecting appropriately.
Here's the hydraulics
group, right?
It's all about the
hydraulic pump, the filters,
and getting hydraulic
pressure to all
the different subsystems.
You know, the big engine
here, the power plant group,
the engine is the
most important thing.
The loft group-- loft means--
lofting is surfaces.
You're dealing with
the shape of surfaces.
So let's keep this simple.
So we have a little,
you know, balsa airplane
with little straight
surfaces, very easy for loft.
Production is kind of similar.
The aerodynamics group wants
a very nice high aspect ratio
wing, very thin, very low drag.
Problem is, there's no room
for passengers or cargo here.
You see this, the stress group?
They have a nice wing here
in the shape of an I-beam.
I-beams are great, you know,
this is good if you're a civil
engineer but not so much--
none of these things
would work on their own.
So what we really
want is something
like this, where all
these considerations are
blended and optimized so we get
a high-performance system not
just a high-performance
subsystem.
Said another way, a
high-performance system
is not the same as just a
sum of individually optimized
subsystems.
That's, in a nutshell,
what MDO is about.
So one of the readings
for today, post readings,
is this paper, 6A.
And this is based on a big
workshop we had in Germany
about five years ago.
That's actually longer.
It's probably seven
years ago by now,
but the paper came
out five years ago
called, "MDO, Assessment and
Direction for Advancement."
And this is a pretty
international group
that put this together.
And what we do in the paper,
we describe the history
of multidisciplinary
optimization, where
it is today, where it's heading,
and some of the key milestones.
So this chart is essentially
a kind of history of MDO.
I'm just gonna point
out a few things.
The roots of MDO are in
structural optimization.
So you saw the bracket
with all those--
so there's actually a field
called structural optimization
or topology optimization,
and it's very mature now.
So you can buy, in some
of the CAD packages,
there's some specialized tools
for optimizing structures.
And when you look at it,
it looks like Swiss cheese
with big holes, an
Emmentaler, big holes.
You don't need a
lot of structure
that doesn't do work for you.
So a lot of these
structures look like webs,
and the reason is
because the load
path has been highly optimized.
For example, if you
look at the A380--
I don't have a
picture right here--
but you can look at an A380 wing
spars and different structures.
They have more
holes than structure
because they've been
highly optimized.
So that's the roots of
MDO, starting in the 1960s.
Then, I would say, in the '80s,
mid-'80s, we started having
more complex
decomposition techniques,
and I will describe one
of these to you today.
Optimization
algorithms were started
to be built into
mainstream programs
like Excel, MATLAB, Mathematica.
And then more recently,
you know, in the 2000s,
we had commercialization
of multilevel algorithms,
and the one that I'll describe
to you is called BLISS.
So let's talk through a very
specific example, and then
one of those techniques.
So here's the example.
You're designing a wing,
and in designing a wing,
the two main considerations
are structural and aerodynamic.
So here's a simplified wing.
It has a wing area,
it has a sweep angle,
it has an aspect
ratio, and so forth.
And there's loads
acting on the wing
as you're flying
because of the pressure
differential between the
upper and lower surface.
So there's some net force,
P, acting on this wing.
And as a result of that,
the wing will warp.
So you will have some
twist angle in the wing,
and that's just due to the
structural deformation.
So that twist angle and
the displacements, in turn,
will change the drag that
the wing experiences.
So the lift and drag
of the wing will change
as a function of twist angle.
But as the lift and drag
change, the loads, of course,
then change as well, and it
feeds back into the structure.
And in this case, what we're
looking for is maximum range.
We want to maximize the
range of the airplane.
And this is a sort
of simplified version
of the range equation, the
so-called Breguet range
equation.
And you can see that
the structure influences
the range in two ways--
directly by weight,
the actual weight
of the structure
enters here twice in the range
equation, and then indirectly
through its stiffness, right?
The softer it is, the more
displacements, the more
you affect the drag.
So it's not so clear then
what is an optimal wing?
Is it the lightest
wing possible?
But the lightest wing possible
will have a larger twist
and may have more drag, which
will reduce your range, right?
So should you optimize
the wing for lightness
or for this minimum
displacement or some combination
or mix of the two?
And the answer, of course,
is it's a mix of the two.
There will be a
sweet spot somewhere,
you know, between a very
stiff and very heavy
wing and a very, very
flexible, lightweight wing.
There will be some
optimal mix of the two,
and that's the key here.
So let me discuss
with you briefly--
this is just one of the methods.
There are several methods for
doing multidisciplinary design
optimization, but
this is one of them
called BLISS, Bi-Level
Integrated Systems Synthesis.
And the general idea
here in this method
is that we have a lower level
optimization of each subsystem
but it's coupled through a
system level optimization.
And what you want is, you
know, an optimal design
at the system level, not
just optimal subsystems.
So the context
here is we're gonna
design a high speed, a
supersonic business jet.
It's kind of shown
in this gray picture.
And we have four
major subsystems
we're gonna consider--
propulsion, aerodynamics,
structures, and then
the performance, which,
in this case, is range, OK?
And what's important here in
decomposing the problem is
the x's and the y's.
Now, the x's are the
design variables.
Do you remember, we talk
about the design variables,
the knobs you can
turn as a designer?
And so these here
are-- the upper ones,
we call them local design
variables, you know,
like the throttle setting, the
tail sweep, the wing moment
arm, the thickness of the
wings, the taper ratio.
So the idea of a
local design variable
is that design variable only is
used in one of the subsystems.
It's local to that subsystem.
So you basically can choose
that in each of the subsystems,
and it doesn't really
affect directly
any of the other
subsystems-- indirectly, yes,
but not directly.
And then we have the y's here.
The y's are the outputs from
one subsystem to another.
So drag, lift, NZ is
your maximum load factor,
your range, your specific fuel
consumption, your wing twist,
and so forth.
So those are outputs from a
subsystem or discipline that
either matter at
the system level
or are required as inputs
by another subsystem.
And then finally, the
last group here, these
are known as the shared
design variables,
so the wing aspect
ratio, the altitude,
mach number, wing sweep.
Those are basically required
by more than one subsystem, so
two, three, or
four, in this case.
Then they are considered
as shared variables,
and they would be considered
system level variables
because they matter for
more than one subsystem.
So what this
particular method does
is essentially
decompose the problem
into the various subsystems,
so in this case, again,
aerodynamics, propulsion,
structures, and range.
And these subsystems are sending
this information to each other
and are all tied together
at the highest level
through the shared
variables, the shared design
variables that are shared
by at least two subsystems.
So again, local
variables are only
unique to a specific subsystem,
and then for the wise,
these outputs, internal
outputs, there's
a distinction between
the Y stars, which
are coupling variables that are
input to a particular subsystem
and then the Y hats
are coupling variables
that are output from a
particular subsystem.
So let's zoom in now on
just one of the subsystems,
let's say, aerodynamics,
and see how this works.
So here we're zooming
in on one subsystem,
and that's the aerodynamics.
And the idea that
you can actually
optimize just the aerodynamic
subsystem by itself.
So what are the inputs into it?
We have aspect ratio, wing
twist, and W. So what is W?
And this is key to this
particular method--
the W are the
weights, the weights
that you give to the outputs.
So what you're optimizing here
is some objective function, f,
shown here below, which is W1,
Y1, plus W2, Y2 plus W3, Y3.
So you're either maximizing
or minimizing that.
And what is this here?
It's lift, drag, and
the lift to drag ratio.
So what's really cool
about this method is
that what it essentially
is telling the subsystem
is how to properly weight these
different outputs in order
to optimize the
subsystem, taking into
account the system
level objective.
So the weights are
not pre-defined,
but the weights themselves
are a design variable.
And so you can see the
formulation on the right side.
So given Q, which is
your shared variables,
the Y stars, which
are the inputs
from the other subsystems,
and the weights,
minimize your objective function
by varying your local design
variables subject to a
bunch of constraints, OK?
And so what is one
of the consequences
of being able to formulate
the problem this way?
So this could be a very high
fidelity, aerodynamics model,
computational fluid dynamics,
or it could be what?
Or it could be a lower
fidelity code, right?
As long as the inputs and
the outputs are the same,
you can now plug in, you know,
different fidelity levels
of analysis, you know
something simple or something
based on experimental
results, you
know, panel method,
very high fidelity CFD.
This becomes very modular.
The other thing
you can do is you
can pre-compute a lot of
these responses, right?
So for a given
set of inputs, you
can pre-compute over a whole
range of input variables
what the response of
that subsystem will be,
and you can store
that information
and then use what are
known approximation
methods, like response
surface models,
to save that information,
such that when
you do the full
system optimization,
you don't have to rerun,
you know, the detailed codes
every time.
You can just pull
from the approximation
you've pre-computed already.
So that's one of the
really powerful things
about this method.
And that's what's shown
here, is you substitute--
you have a series of
approximation models, one
for each of the
outputs of the system.
You see that?
So these little
wiggly things here
are essentially an
approximation of
that input/output relationship
at the subsystem level.
Could be an empirical function,
a neural network, a response
surface method, or you
know, simplified engineering
analysis.
So you do a lot of this
work offline ahead of time
for each of the subsystems.
Does that make sense?
Any questions at EPFL?
Is that clear how this
works, at least in theory?
AUDIENCE: Everything's
fine, thanks.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, so what
we have now is essentially
these subsystem approximations,
and now we can use them
for system level optimization.
So now let's look at the
system level optimization.
So that's essentially
given approximation
models for optimized
subsystem outputs,
we want to minimize
some objective function.
So F, here in this case, which
is a function of our shared
variables, our relevant outputs,
Y star, and the weighting
factors, right, the omega--
not the omegas, the W's, which
are the weighting factors given
to each of the subsystems.
And we of course, have
to satisfy constraints
at the system level.
So let me show you an example
then of what this looks like.
So here's our supersonic jet.
This is our cycle zero,
our initial condition.
Here's the planned
form of the jet,
and I'm going to show
you down here range
and just one of the design
variables, or a set of design
variables, which is our
wing box sheet thickness.
So you go through this, and
it converges after 10 cycles
already.
So this is what our business
jet looks like after 10 cycles.
And you know, you see there's
a pretty big difference.
So the fuselage is much longer.
This by the way, this is
the same in ships, right?
Your speed that you can
reach, your max speed
is driven by your fuselage
length, your water length.
You can see the wings have
a pretty high sweep angle.
This is a supersonic jet.
And if we look at
the details, we
see that the range
here, the range
is about 3,000 nautical
miles, and what
you see is that the exact
range that can be achieved
and the approximate range merge.
So the approximation models
that you have in this method
are only approximate.
There's some error.
And you know, as you run
the model several times,
several iterations,
the difference
between the approximation and
the actual high fidelity result
gets less and less, so that
it's actually a feasible design.
And then over here, we see
the different thicknesses
for the inner wing
box, the mid span wing
box, and the outer wing box.
And you can see that early
on in the first four or five
six iterations, things
are kind of moving around,
but then they're settling out.
And so for this maximum
objective of range,
you can see that the inner, mid,
and outer wing box thicknesses
are quite different.
So that's the general idea
here is that this result--
this is a fairly detailed design
was produced based on a system
level optimization that
included consideration
of aerodynamic structures,
propulsion, and so forth.
And there are several
other methods,
but this is just one
of the methods that's
been actually quite helpful.
The challenges now in MDO,
in this multidisciplinary
optimization are
different trade-offs.
So one trade-off is between
fidelity versus how expensive
is it computationally.
So fidelity is over here.
So high fidelity
means, you know,
3D finite element model
analysis, computational fluid
dynamics.
Then you have sort of
intermediate fidelity
or low fidelity
empirical models.
And then on this axis, we
have just doing trade studies,
meaning you have sort
of a baseline design
and you just explore from
that baseline design.
You do limited optimization
or iteration or full MDO,
exploring the full space.
And traditionally,
you had to choose,
am I gonna use high
fidelity models?
But then I can only
look at a few points.
So then the question
is can you do better?
Is there a better
solution out there?
Or you can do lower
fidelity models
and explore the design
space very widely,
and then the
question is, can you
believe the results
because you've done
this with approximate models?
So the real challenge here is we
would like to do high fidelity
and explore the
full design space.
So that's one of the big
research areas in MDO
is high fidelity but also very
computationally efficient.
And then the other
challenge is quite similar.
So it's again the
fidelity here, but then
should you just focus
on one subsystem?
How many of the subsystems,
including, you know,
the financial, operations,
manufacturing considerations,
so how many of those
subsystems do you
include in your optimization?
And so you know, ideally, you'd
like to do the complete system,
but then you may
have to sacrifice
on some of the fidelity.
So that's the breadth
versus depth trade-off.
OK so any questions about--
I know this was very fast.
I do not expect you, by the
way, for assignment four or five
to do MDO on your CanSat.
This is really more to give
you a feeling for, you know,
how far things
have come and some
of the computational
frameworks that
exist to get you to a really
fine tuned optimized design.
If you are interested
in this, you know,
we have the spring class.
And you know, I hadn't offered
this class at EPFL in the past,
but we actually do
offer a distance version
with the SDM program.
So there may be an option to
do this at a distance as well.
We'll discuss it.
But any questions about MDO?
What it is, how it works,
at least in principle?
Has anybody done
MDO kind of work?
Sam, go ahead
AUDIENCE: I just had
one question about if--
so here, we're looking at
optimizing on one attribute, so
range, but if we have
multiple attributes,
it's still up to
someone to decide
how important those
attributes are in the end.
OLIVIER DE WECK: That's correct.
That is exactly
right, unless you
have a way to combine all these
into one objective function.
And to be blatant
about it, to be-- you
know, in the commercial
world, that's actually clear.
It's profit or
net present value.
So if you're designing
a commercial product
in a competitive
industry, you can actually
pretty easily combine
all this into a long--
you know, as long as you include
sort of the key drivers of,
you know, your
manufacturing costs.
If the product is not as
optimal and not as performant,
well, probably, you're not
gonna be as successful.
Your market share
might be lower.
So in the commercial
world, people
are doing MDO with profitability
as the ultimate objective
function.
Now, for situations where it's
not about profit necessarily,
but it's about a bunch
of other considerations,
then you can't
easily combine it.
You can still do utility.
You can do a utility, you
know, combine it in utility.
But I agree with you, I think
a good practice is then,
in that case, to do
the multi-objective,
and then you're gonna have
a bunch of solutions that
are all non-dominated, right?
And then it's a human
decision making process
to pick among those.
Any other questions or comments?
What about at EPFL?
MDO, anybody have
experience with this before,
multidisciplinary
design optimization?
AUDIENCE: OK, no one, again.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK,
that's all right.
So just to tell you, this is
really a big deal in practice.
So you know, the structural
optimization has been around,
that's pretty standard
practice, and you know,
optimizing control systems.
So we've optimized individual
subsystems for a long time now,
at least two or three decades,
but optimizing at the system
level is relatively new.
And I think the best companies,
the best organizations that
are out there, they're really
investing in this technology,
and they're quite good at it.
And that's where you can
really distinguish yourself
from the competition.
So let's talk about
concurrent design facilities.
And so I'm actually going to
use some material here from EPFL
because they have
a very nice CDF,
and I want to give
credit here to Dr. Anton
Ivanov at the Swiss Space Center
for some of this material.
And actually one of the papers
is also related to this.
Anton used to be at JPL.
He worked at JPL for close to
a decade before going to EPFL.
So what is a CDF, a
concurrent design facility?
It's essentially an
environment where
engineers of
different disciplines
come together to
perform, you know,
a system engineering
study for a project.
Key elements that you need
is the team, the process,
the physical environment,
which includes
the A/V and the software,
and then also some way
to do knowledge
management, meaning
capturing the results of prior
studies and ongoing studies.
And I'll show you
some examples of CDFs.
We also do this in academia.
There's challenges for
doing this in academia,
a short learning curve, you
know, synchronizing this
with the academic
schedule, and then
a lot of turnover, of course, as
students graduate and so forth.
So there's challenges.
And in practice, what we
essentially have is, in a CDF,
we have a set of models that
are linked to each other.
And these models can
be, for example, here's
some Simulink models shown.
Here, there is
some Excel models.
You can have CAD.
And one of the tricks is, you
know, to link this together
in a way that you can quickly
execute different designs
and look at the
results from that.
So in industrial settings,
probably the most famous CDF
is the one at JPL, at the
Jet Propulsion Laboratory,
called Team X. Team X has been
around for about 20 years,
and they just had an anniversary
where they celebrated
their 1000th study that was
done at Team X. A typical Team X
study is about a week.
So you do a little
bit of preparation,
but people work together in
the facility for about a week,
and at the end of
the week, you have
basically a conceptual design
pretty well worked out.
And the results have
been impressive.
So studies have shown
that the cost estimates
that Team X came up with were
within 10% of final mission
costs, for those missions that
were actually built and flown.
So of the 1,000 studies that
Team X did, a handful of them
were actual flight missions.
But every proposal
that is written
starts now as a Team X study.
So it's really a big deal.
The European Space Agency
ESTEC has a similar facility
in Noordwijk in the Netherlands.
As well, all the ESA projects
are going through their CDF.
So one of these is
[INAUDIBLE] which
is a space-based observatory.
EPFL is involved
in that project.
That went through
the CDF as well.
Most NASA centers and then
commercial applications
in medical devices,
painting, shipbuilding.
And like I mentioned
in my introduction,
even consumer packaged
good companies
are now building their
version of a CDF,
such that they can, you know,
very quickly, within a couple
weeks, come up with a new
proposal for a product and all
the major aspects, you
know, the underlying physics
and chemistry, the packaging,
the business case, everything
is considered at the same time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering why--
what makes the cost estimate
so accurate with this method?
OLIVIER DE WECK: So there
are three major ways
of doing-- oh,
Veronica should answer
that question, since
she's launching on cost
modeling for her research.
There are three major
cost estimation methods.
One is bottom up, you know, you
have the product decomposition,
and you add up all the costs.
One is called
costing by analogy,
where you look at a prior
mission or a prior product
and then you look at the deltas.
And then the third one is
based on so-called CERs,
cost estimation relationships.
It's a parametric method.
You can also blend these.
And you know, I think one of
the reasons why it's accurate
is because--
there are two reasons
why, I would say.
So you always have a cost share.
One of the subsystems
is costing.
So you have really people who
been doing this for a while.
They know these
models, and so there's
some legacy information.
And the more missions we fly,
the more products we make,
the more robust, essentially,
these cost estimates become.
And then the second, I think,
is because people that typically
work in a CDF,
they're non-advocates,
meaning it's kind
of neutral ground.
So rather than pushing
a particular idea
or trying to be
overly optimistic,
you know, usually in a
CDF, the calculations
that are done are
pretty non-biased,
and that's not always the case.
So that's one of the advantages
of the CDF is you're getting--
you know, people are trying
to say, but really, let's
make it look a little better.
No, no, we can't do this,
because the model says,
you know, it is gonna cost $280
million to do this satellite.
And that's based on, you
know, within prior models,
and if you overlay
different models,
you know, with some
error or confidence.
That's the right answer.
So it's these two reasons.
There's experience, there's
data, and non-advocacy, really
taking a kind of neutral,
unbiased position.
So benefits are, you know,
improvements of quality,
quick turnaround for ideas,
better cost estimates,
and then increased creativity
and productivity in a company.
So let me give you a
couple examples here.
This is a CubeSat.
So this is the ability to
design quickly new CubeSats.
This picture here
I'm showing you
is the Swiss Cube that was
launched in 2009, still
operating.
I think it's the longest
operating, continuously
operating CubeSat so far.
There's like over six years
of operational data now.
And so you know, for the
next generation, which
is shown here, how would you do
a Cubesat in such a facility?
And there's three steps.
You define your
decomposition level.
So you have your system
level, your subsystem level,
and then at the lowest
level it's called equipment.
These are the actual components.
And you have your product
decomposition here,
and then for each
of these components,
you have different sheets
that give you either component
choices or give you different
parameters like mass power
with margins that allow
you to then choose
from this like a menu and pull
together your overall design.
So that's a Cubesat example.
But I want to talk
to you a little bit
in more detail through a design
of a suborbital space plane
that was done in
that CDF, and this
was a project known as K1000.
So some of you may have heard
of the Hermes, the Hermes space
plane.
This was a project that the
European Space Agency had
starting even in the
'80s, and it wasn't built,
but there was a lot
of studies done.
And this is essentially
a Hermes-like vehicle
but for space tourism,
that's the basic application.
And so you know, how would
you design a space tourism
vehicle in a CDF?
Well, you have to start
with requirements, right?
Without requirements, you're
just-- it's like, you know,
setting--
my analogy for designing
without requirements
is like taking your ship and
going out to sea without a map,
without a chart, with no
destination port in mind.
You're just drifting
in the ocean.
You've got to have requirements.
So here are the high
level requirements
for this particular vehicle.
Level one
requirements-- you have
to reach an altitude of at least
100 kilometers over sea level.
Why is that?
Where does the 100
kilometers come from?
Why is it not 80 or 90 or 150?
AUDIENCE: That's where
space is defined.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Right,
and what happens to people
who go above 100 kilometers?
AUDIENCE: They get
their astronaut wings.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
They get their--
you have gone to
space, and like,
you know, you can
claim that you've gone
to space if you go above 100.
If you don't, if you are
at 80 or 90 you don't.
That's kind of
internationally accepted.
So that's really where that
requirement comes from.
The second one is
a zero g phase.
You should experience
weightlessness
for at least several minutes.
Who's done a parabolic
flight before here?
The zero g, you know,
the Vomit Comet?
Anybody?
Wow, we have to get
you guys out there.
At EPFL, are you still with us?
AUDIENCE: We are.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Has anybody
done parabolic flights?
I know there's a flight campaign
coming up in Switzerland
later this year?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it will
be next year, I guess,
but unfortunately, no one
has done this right now here.
OLIVIER DE WECK: All right,
guys, we have to fix this.
This is unacceptable.
I mean, we have to work on this.
So it's very cool to do
these parabolic flights,
but you only get about
20 seconds, right?
20 seconds at the top.
It's like riding a big
roller coaster, basically.
And then you go down, and
then you suffer, you know,
1.7 g's or whatever.
Then you come back up.
But we want several minutes.
And then the next requirement
is that the passengers
should carry-- there should
be six passengers carried
on this vehicle.
Those are the top
level one requirements.
Lower level-- level two
requirements-- safety.
Don't exceed six g,
positive six g's.
The vehicle must be
controllable at all times.
So when you're out
of the atmosphere,
you have to be able to
control the vehicle, that
has certain implications.
The customer
experience-- you should
be able to see the Earth's
curvature and atmosphere,
that thin layer, at all times.
The spacecraft impact
on the environment
should be as small as possible.
And then the mass budget,
the spacecraft mass
should not exceed 11.6
tons with propellants.
Where do you think
that comes from?
What kind of a
requirement is that?
What flavor of
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Transporting it
for proper [INAUDIBLE]..
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Right, so in this case,
it's actually a
piggyback, right?
You either have
a vertical launch
or you have a first stage,
an airplane from which you
are dropped right?
So that's sort of an
interface requirement.
OK, so once you know
your requirements,
you can really start
developing your models.
So here's a model of essentially
the kinematics of the vehicle.
So you have your environment,
your atmospheric model,
atmospheric density, pressure,
mach number, speed of sound,
a gravity model.
Then computing the forces and
torques acting on the vehicle
itself, looking at the
derivatives, integrating that.
This is essentially
the equations
of motion of a vehicle
in its environment
that it's operating
in, and then updating
that with a certain
time step, delta T.
So you can zoom in
on one of these,
for example, this force model,
computation of the forces.
And there's two frames.
There's the Earth
reference frame
and, then there's the
body centric frame
of the vehicle itself.
So you have, in this case,
the aerodynamic coefficients.
You have the forces, lift,
drag, pitching moment,
and then you have the actuation.
This is assumed, you know, the
pilots are here in control.
The rocket engine itself,
secondary propulsion,
the rudders, and then
attitude thrusters.
You need those especially--
you know, once you're out of
the atmosphere, the rudders--
the aerodynamic surfaces
are no longer effective.
And we knew this in the '60s.
Vehicles-- like the
X15 is very famous.
Well, it had thrusters
that you could
you could actuate once
you're out of the atmosphere.
So you know, you can go
pretty detailed in this.
You would then design the
vehicle in a particular way,
you know, particular engine,
wing dimensions, aspect ratio,
a particular flight
profile, and then
that would be a typical result
that you would get in a CDF.
There's two curves shown here.
The blue curve is essentially
altitude and kilometers.
So you see there's
the 100 kilometers.
We need to get
above this, right?
This was our requirement.
So we go above 100.
That's good.
We satisfy that requirement.
So looks like a
parabola, and then we
have a-- we glide here,
essentially, to the ground.
The whole mission takes about
900 seconds, 15 minutes.
And then the yellow curve here
is your load factor, your NZ,
your vertical load factor.
And you can see that's a
little noisier as a curve.
So we have higher acceleration
as we accelerate to altitude.
And you can see that
roughly here, roughly
in the middle of the parabola,
the load factor starts to--
you're basically in free fall.
You're basically ballistic,
and the peak acceleration
is about 4.3 g's here, so
we satisfy that requirement.
And the whole reason we're doing
it is for this period here,
that zero g experience.
So when the load factor
goes to zero, or near zero,
that's when you
get weightlessness.
And it turns out for this
particular flight profile,
we would experience 184
seconds, about three minutes
of weightlessness.
This is pretty similar
to the flight profile
that Virgin Galactic is
pursuing, by the way.
So you know, looking at
this result, you would say,
well, I don't know about
the mass here, but from,
you know, reaching
100 kilometers keeping
accelerations below six g, this
looks like a feasible profile.
Of course, the other
thing that we care about
is the view, since this
is for space tourism.
We want to make
sure that, you know,
that the experience
is great, not just
from an experiencing
weightlessness, which
you can do in a closed can but
you actually see something.
So this was essentially
coupled with a virtual reality
visualization.
So you can see, you
know, the landing here.
You can see these
three views here.
And you can see
the vehicle itself.
So the pilots are up
front, and then here
is our six passengers.
Every one of the passengers
gets their own window.
So this is the
view that you would
get from the front window.
This is the view from
the middle window.
And then this is the view
from the back window,
from that last window here,
which is closer to the back,
to the engines.
So what would you, looking
at these pictures-- you know,
this comes directly out of
the simulation and the CDF--
what would you say
looking at this?
Anything you notice?
EPFL anything you guys notice?
Look at the view from
the front, the middle,
and the back window.
AUDIENCE: From the
front, looks better.
I guess it will be
more expensive, again,
for the customer.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yeah, so that's
exactly what I was asking.
So it looks like either you
need to redesign the vehicle so
that the view is the same, more
or less, from every window,
or you need to start
charging differential prices.
Because clearly,
from the back window,
half your view is obstructed
by the wing structure, right?
Would you agree with that?
Would you charge different
ticket prices for this ride,
depending on which seat you get?
AUDIENCE: I guess
that's offer and demand?
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Supply and demand, yes.
That's right.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It could also merit
a change in flight plan.
If your structure blocks
the downward view,
you might want to
consider flipping over
if like the Earth is what
you're trying to see from above.
So it may have broader
implications for the mission.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK,
so the point here,
is there a way to operationally
improve the experience,
keeping the vehicle
design the same?
Absolutely, but
what that means is,
you would have to
put the operation--
so the orientation
of the vehicle,
you'd have to put that
into your design vector
if you want to change it.
OK, so I don't know.
I think this is pretty cool.
So you can actually do a lot in
this kind of CDF type setting.
And by the way, of the things
that spun out of this project
is this company called S3.
Their headquarters in
Payerne in Switzerland.
This is actually-- I did a
lot of my military service
at that airport.
Their goal is not
space tourism, you
see there's no windows
on this vehicle,
but deployment of small
satellites, custom
deployment for small satellites
with a reusable vehicle.
So you know, I think it's
a very interesting concept,
but the question is,
is it feasible, right?
Is it feasible-- the
aerodynamics, the economics,
structurally, engine reuse?
There's a lot of--
this is a great
picture, but you know,
the devil is in the details.
So really working out the
details of such a design,
that's what a CDF is for,
and you can really go deep.
OK so any questions about this?
I'd like to do a little
partner exercise here.
Any questions?
So let's do a partner
exercise, and the question is,
what are your experiences with
concurrent design facilities
so far?
Whether you've done an
internship at ESA or JPL,
or some other place that
has a facility like this,
or even if you
haven't been there,
kind of speculate and discuss
what it would be like.
Maybe, you know, what would
be your favorite chair?
Would you pick propulsion or
costing or flight trajectory?
You know, just sort of speculate
and discuss with your partner,
so for which project or
application did you use it?
What went well?
What did not?
What could be improved?
And again, if you don't
have much experiences,
just think ahead what
it would be like.
What would you like to
get out of it if you
have no experience in it?
AUDIENCE: So there is at ESA,
a concurrent design facility,
and I was talking with Katya
that maybe also United Nations
can be considered, like,
the facilities there
can be considered a
concurrent design facility.
I don't know if it
worked, this approach.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Do
you mean in Geneva,
United Nations in Geneva
or London or New York,
or do you mean in general?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
But do they actually
have a physical facility
with models and screens,
or are you saying this
more metaphorically?
AUDIENCE: Metaphorically more.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
OK, but you know I--
go ahead.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we're referring
to the layout, to the site,
we're looking at the
ESA layout, where
you have one big room, where
you have all the people coming
together, all the different
models coming together.
So that's like all
the different experts.
Then you have subrooms for
different project rooms,
and then you have, like,
a big conference room.
That's kind of the structure of
the layout of the facilities.
OLIVIER DE WECK: But you know,
maybe a place like the UN
could really benefit when they
deal with a refugee crisis
or with, you know, climate
change negotiations.
I like this idea.
Great suggestion.
What about here at MIT?
Any experiences, thoughts?
Yeah, please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, AFRL, we have
a rapid innovation officer.
He's like a general equivalent
as a civilian, a LOC BOS,
and he basically is tasked with
breaking all the rules in AFRL.
Whereas most projects
take years to complete,
he fields questions from
the field, from the theater,
from war fighters, and
they have an urgent need.
And he gets them a solution
in under 12 months.
So he pulls in all these
experts from industry, academia,
wherever.
He'll lock them in
a room, and they
don't leave until they
come up with a solution.
And he has the money
and the influence,
the backing by the AFRL
Commander to get it done.
OLIVIER DE WECK:
And what does that--
I mean, if you
can share, roughly
what does that facility
look like roughly?
Does it have, like, models
and computers and screens?
AUDIENCE: Just white walls,
like, whiteboard walls,
and they will just be covered
with everybody's ideas
by the time they leave there.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Oh, I see.
So it's not as much
computationally supported.
It's more of a human process.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Cool.
OK.
Great.
Interesting.
Any other experiences?
Anybody been at JPL or
seen a commercial facility
in a commercial company
that does this kind of work?
Please, go ahead, Justice.
AUDIENCE: Well it's
less of a commercial--
I was interning at the Aerospace
Corporation this past summer,
and I was working in their
concurrent design center.
And it uses a similar layout
as JPL's Team X's design, where
it's basically using models.
That they have, like, a group
of engineers who sit at desks,
and there's multiple
engineers per subsystem,
and they just discuss.
They're given a
mission objective,
and they discuss how they can
best design the system based
on that.
And they model it and
optimize it in the subsystem,
and then they feed it back
to a systems level design.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Did
you participate in that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
OLIVIER DE WECK: So what
did you think of it?
AUDIENCE: A lot--
it's a lot to take
in at first just
trying to understand
how each of the models work.
You're not necessarily
supposed to work on each model,
but as an intern, they
wanted me to kind of see
what each of the models would
do and not necessarily exactly
how the optimization techniques
work because I didn't
necessarily understand
it, but just more
of have an idea of how it
actually works as a whole.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, good.
Anybody else at EPFL want
to share any experiences?
AUDIENCE: Apparently not, but
just a problem with the sound.
We didn't hear anything on what
the guy before just told us.
OLIVIER DE WECK: OK, Justice,
did you push the mic button?
OK, yeah, so
basically, he worked--
let me try to summarize.
He worked at the
Aerospace Corporation.
He interned at the
Airspace Corporation.
Was it in Virginia
or California?
California, in California.
And Aerospace Corporation
is like a think tank,
and it was a very similar set
up with different subsystem
experts, different models.
And Justice was saying
one of the big challenges
is so much information,
taking it all in
and understanding all the models
and coupling, and so forth.
So and I agree.
It takes a while.
If you haven't been working
in this environment,
it takes a while to
really get used to it.
So the last thing I'll
say here is that--
well, two things.
One is-- and they're
linked-- one is
that these CDFs are not cheap.
If you really want a
high-functioning CDF,
you have to have people
that are dedicated to this.
You know, the software
licenses expire.
The technology gets old.
You need to not
just use it, but you
need to constantly refresh
a CDF, keep it up to date,
and it just doesn't
happen automatically.
You've got to have
budget for that.
You have to have people who
are dedicated to updating
the models, updating the
facility, and so forth.
So it's definitely
something that
needs to be invested
in on a regular basis.
So what happened to us
here at MIT in air astro,
actually, when I
was sitting where
you are sitting
as a grad student,
we created a CDF
in the mid '90s.
And you know, it was
just like the one at JPL.
We had desktops, you know, with
labels-- thermal, propulsion.
And we used it quite
actively for maybe five, six,
seven years, but we didn't put
the budget into it every year.
We didn't have a dedicated
person who was really.
looking after it.
So what happened to our CDF
is that entropy took over,
and it sort of got
more and more dated.
And when you go and
look in this room now,
it kind of looks like a
regular conference room.
So all the desktops
that we had are gone.
I guess they'd be
pretty old by now.
And there has been a pretty
strong debate among the faculty
whether actually we need this.
Should we recreate one?
And the argument
goes as follows,
the proponents say that a CDF
is really something special.
When you enter in the CDF, you
know this is a special place.
This is a facility that's
designed specifically
for doing rapid studies.
All the information
you need is there.
The walls are plastered
with reference information.
You know, really,
that's what it's for.
The counter argument is that
this is no longer the mid-'90s.
Now, everybody has laptops.
Everybody does mobile computing.
All the models and data
should be on the cloud,
not sitting anymore in a
dedicated server facility,
but it's sitting on the cloud.
And therefore, you
know, physically,
a facility that's dedicated
is no longer needed.
What you do is you
get together in a more
kind of flexible ad hoc way.
Everybody brings their laptops.
You have the big white
walls, like you said.
And you can just create
a CDF on the fly, right?
Everybody brings their
computing resources.
Stuff is on the cloud.
And then you get a lot done,
and then you disband again.
You clean the white
boards and you're done.
Therefore, no longer
needed a dedicated CDF.
Those are the two countervailing
opinions right now.
My view is, I think a CDF
still has value today.
I think it is valuable
as a dedicated facility,
but it needs to be updated.
So yes, the models
should be on the cloud.
Yes, you can bring your
laptops, but it is still
valuable to have dedicated
computing resources, again.
So I now think a hybrid model
is actually the right way to go.
So we'll see where it goes, but
it's a pretty active debate.
There have also been,
you know, theses
written on CDFs, comparing
different CDFs and so forth.
So take a look at the Anton
Ivanov paper in the reading
and just think about this.
I think this is a
big deal, and it's
going to be even more important
than the future, whether you're
doing space missions,
aeronautics,
whether you're designing
commercial products,
you know, or in the
military, these facilities
that allow you to make these
design decisions in a very
interactive, very
quick way are gonna
be more and more
important in the future,
and this is a big part
of system engineering.
Any final thoughts on
this before we move on?
OK, so here some lessons
learned from the EPFL CDF.
So this is particularly in
the university environment,
so you know, giving access
to a wide body of students.
You need to adapt this to
the university's schedule,
the learning curves, the analogy
of a smoke-filled room or war
room, optimal team size.
You know a CDF with 50 people
on it is not as effective as one
with, you know, seven
plus or minus two.
And then distributed CDFs--
they don't typically
work as well.
So I almost wore my--
I have a shirt that's
almost the same.
Anybody know who this is
or where this is from?
This is Sheldon Cooper
in the Big Bang Theory,
his virtual reality presence.
So the point here is that
virtual reality is OK.
So you can imagine a CDF where
half the people are in the room
and half the people are
dialing in remotely,
but it's never quite as good as
everybody is there physically.
So human interaction
is critical.
OK, the last thing I want to
talk about today is the CDR.
This is a big, big milestone.
This is a very big deal.
The critical design review,
the main purpose of it
is to approve the final
design in all its glory,
in all its details.
So generally, the
way we talk about it
is, if you pass the CDR, you've
got the green light to quote,
end quote, cut metal.
Of course, you know, our systems
have software and hardware.
So the cut metal is
essentially a euphemism
for you can go ahead and
manufacture the system now.
CDRs are typically
the biggest review.
The largest number of people
you will have at the CDR.
You know, if you had
10 people at the SRR
and 20 people at the
PDR, you're gonna
have 50 or 100
people at the CDR.
Because any question that
comes up on any of the parts--
say, is this really right?
Well, what could be the
impact of this detail
on the rest of the systems?
Somebody should be there
who designed that part
or who can answer the
question at least.
And CDRs are typically
longer than one day.
In fact, for a
big project, a CDR
can be a whole week of reviews.
So people get really tired.
Big CDRs are very,
very detailed.
You really have to drink lots
of coffee and stay awake.
So here's the description
of what a CDR is.
One of the guidelines is
that approximately 90%
of the engineering drawings
are approved and released.
So it's OK to have a CDR if
you have not 100% of everything
done, but you need to have
at least 90% complete.
You can't do a CDR, with, you
know, half the drawings done.
And it happens at the end
of phase C, the final design
phase C.
For very large projects,
you can have sub CDRs.
You'll have a system
level CDR, and then you
can have sub CDRs for
every major subsystem
in your project.
So an example, I
put a link here.
This is from late 2014, the
CDR for the James Webb Space
Telescope that I
mentioned earlier.
They passed the last
major element level
critical design review,
which was a big deal.
So launch is planned for 2018.
But for big projects,
what I'm trying to say is,
there may be more
than one CDR. There
may be the master CDR
for the whole thing
and then sub CDRs for
different subsystems.
Now, if you don't-- well, let me
get to this on the next chart.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Are the, like, CDR
slides for NASA projects,
are those available
anywhere as a public entity
and can you get access
to any of that stuff?
OLIVIER DE WECK: It depends.
Not always, because especially
if commercial companies,
like, you know, Lockheed-Martin
or somebody is doing, like,
the spacecraft bus, they
would consider those details
proprietary.
So in general, I would say no.
But for CanSat, actually, you've
probably already found them.
For CanSat, you can
actually find a lot of this.
So prior PDRs and
CDRs, you can see that.
I encourage you not
to look too much.
You know, you kind of want to
come up with your own thing.
But you know, for
projects that don't
have a commercial interest
or proprietary technology,
it's often available.
So to show you just-- this is
a table from the Handbook, page
178.
This is the entrance criteria
and the exit criteria for CDR.
So entrance criteria means what
do you have to have in order
to be allowed to go
forward with a CDR?
And it's mainly three things--
successful completion of
the PDR, and responses
made to all the
PDR RFAs and RIDs.
RFAs and RIDs are essentially
deficiencies, open items
that came up in the PDR.
So you have to close them out.
A CDR agenda, and
then number three
is all the technical
work packages.
And so you see, it's
a huge list here--
baseline documents,
specification, fabrication,
assembly and integration,
technical data package,
acceptance criteria,
verification and validation
plan, launch site selection,
and operations plan--
super, super, super detailed.
This is a lot of information.
And at the CDR, you're
gonna go through all this.
So you can imagine
what that means.
And then success
criteria, on the right,
is, you know, in order to
successfully pass the CDR,
these are all the things that
you have to basically have.
You have to have approval
for all these things.
Now in reality, just
like a PDR, at a CDR,
things will come
up that you missed
or that people have
concerns about.
And so you will make
a list of those,
and then you have to address
these action items coming out
of a CDR. If those action
items are serious--
if they're really serious, you
could fail the CDR and say,
you know, this is
not gonna work.
We should not proceed.
And they send you back.
Or they cancel the project.
That's happened also.
More likely, is that they'll
ask you to do a so-called delta
CDR. So they'll
have you, you know,
it's like retaking
an exam or something.
They'll have you
come back, and you'll
have to do a CDR again but
only on the delta, the portion
that raised concerns
at the main CDR.
You don't have to
do everything again.
That's called a delta CDR.
OK, any questions about CDR?
This is really the--
this is the big one.
This is the big milestone.
And obviously, you know, the
concept or the architecture
you chose at the PDR turns
out not to be a good one,
it's very difficult to make
changes to that here, right?
You're kind of locked in to
whatever design or architecture
you chose at PDR.
That's why PDR is also
so important, even
though you have less detail.
Yeah, Sam, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Do you have to
have contracts in place
already for the, like,
manufacturing and operations?
OLIVIER DE WECK: Oh, absolutely.
I mean, basically green
light CDR, the next day,
you start manufacturing.
So you know, every portion,
all the components,
all the manufacturing,
all of that
has been bid,
selected, contracted.
Everything's in place
contractually, absolutely.
OK, any questions
at EPFL about CDR?
Who has actually gone
through a CDR on your end?
Has anybody done a CDR
for any of the projects?
OK, go ahead.
What was it like?
AUDIENCE: I did also a CDR
because I had the PDR last time
at the [INAUDIBLE] program.
And one comment I want to make.
So the teams were allowed to
fail the PDR and still fly.
If they failed the CDR,
then they didn't fly at all.
So it was very
strict and demanding
OLIVIER DE WECK:
Yeah, so would you
say that the CDR is more
strict than the PDR?
AUDIENCE: The CDR
is more strict.
OLIVIER DE WECK: Yes, I agree.
I agree.
Definitely.
OK, anybody else?
Are any of you working in
systems other than aerospace,
like, I don't know, medical
devices or you know,
scientific instruments?
So the reason I bring
this up is because you
know, medical devices have to
be approved by, here in the US,
it's the FDA, the Food
and Drug Administration,
and then in Europe, there
is equivalent, you know,
European level thing.
It's very, very detailed.
It's really not that different.
So presenting your
medical device design
to a panel of experts--
doctors, you know, people in
medical safety, regulators--
it is like a CDR. You basically
are going through a CDR
when you're trying to get
your medical device approved
for sale and use.
So it's not often called a CDR,
but it effectively is a CDR.
So this is, especially
in industries
where there's a lot of
money at stake and people,
you know, safety, people's
health is at stake,
this is common practice.
OK, so let me summarize here.
So this is the detailed
design phase we discussed.
It's very important.
Basically, you take
your PDR level design
and you go define all the
details in full maturity.
You create design
documents and models.
And you know, as we
talked about last time,
we're sort of in
this transition phase
of producing documents
versus producing models.
Typically, we have both now.
Examples would be detailed
bill of materials,
computer-aided design files--
we'll talk about CAD next week,
computer-aided design--
software and control
system definition,
user interfaces, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera.
Multidisciplinary
design optimization
is a very powerful
concept to optimize
at the system and
the subsystem level
and trade off between
disciplines and objectives.
The CDFs are the concurrent
design facilities,
and they've now become standard
practice both in aerospace
and product design companies.
If you have not had the
chance to experience and work
in a CDF, I really
encourage you to do this.
I think it's a
life-changing experience.
It really-- it's not easy,
because like, you know, Justice
said, there's a lot of
information to absorb.
But once you've done
this and experienced it,
you realize if you
don't have a CDF,
if you don't design products
this way, you really should.
And then CDR is
the big milestone,
the last gate before, quote,
end quote, cutting metal.